in a shocking development conservative
airhorn and thinking man Swamp Thing
Bill O'Reilly has been this comes amid
revelations that the network paid out
multi millions to settle multiple sexual
harassment suits and bombing Lee
famously furious hosts when he's not
aimlessly shouting and harassing women
who wore formal Riley moonlights as the
best-selling author of killing Lincoln
killing Kennedy and killing Reagan the
next book will be killing my own career
bills already transitioning from the no
spin zone to the no job zone on vacation
today you photograph from heat oh uh
guys cat I wonder if he had anything to
confess I don't know that is really fun
if you get fired for a raft of sexual
harassment charges you can always find a
job in the Catholic charge hey
hello
comedians with the recent four years of
Catholic High School four years four
years
feather guys school with the recent
departures of O'Reilly and megyn kelly
it seems like the conservative news
network is either trying to get rid of
every Irish person who works there or
undergoing major changes what is next
for Fox News Marcela
I don't know Chris but it'll definitely
be racist as they use all these
disasters justified never hiring women
again because if they weren't around
none of this what a happy time
that's it words I like you guys to make
the clarification oh yes I said tell me
I'm not me yeah I love my mama so rough
much Ross Marquand uh they're gonna get
George Clooney to come in there and do
the fantastic mr. Fox News oh that's
fantastic well I wonder if George
Clooney were here right now what he
would say why'd I just did that